[Musik]
hunderttausende trauern um general
suleiman
die iranische führung droht den usa mit
rache und vergeltung überraschende
bilanz in klimaschutz deutschland ließ
im vergangenen jahr 35 prozent weniger
co2 in die luft als 1990
und drei tage vor der handball-em die
deutsche mannschaft gewinnt den letzten
test in österreich
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesen sechster januar den sport in der
sendung präsentiert norbert lammert eine
schöne oder andere familie die sorge vor
einer weiteren eskalation zwischen iran
irak und den usa beherrscht die
weltpolitik nach der tötung von general
zu lehman ii droht irans regierung
weiter mit vergeltung und findet
offenbar auch bei vielen zustimmung die
sie sonst nicht unterstützen
im ganzen land gibt es seit tagen
trauerfeierlichkeiten eine patriotische
demonstration der iranischen regierung
und hunderttausende schließen sich an
erklären den getöteten general zum
märtyrer die gewaltigste menschenmenge
versammelte sich heute in der hauptstadt
teheran
von dort jörg brase die zeremonie auf
dem gelände der universität in teheran
ist nicht nur trauerfeier sondern auch
fanal gegen amerika und seine
verbündeten iran staatsführung nimmt
abschied tränen bei religionsführer
ayatollah khamenei und justizminister
reise einen ihrer engsten vertrauten und
gefährten im kampf gegen irans erzfeind
de haben sie verloren das so schwören
religiöse wie militärs soll nicht ohne
folgen bleiben selten viel ist der
iranischen staatsführung leichter die
massen gegen amerika auf die straßen zu
bringen als heute solle man isaac waren
sich nach dem trauer gebet seinen weg
durch hunderttausende menschen der anz
innenstadt ist völlig blockiert und sie
alle sind wütend auf jenen mann in
washington der den befehl gab so lemond
nie zu tun
sie werden auch eines morgens aufwachen
herr tram und schlechte nachrichten
hören wir sind bereit und wir haben
einen plan diese hinrichtung zu recht
wir müssen so hart wie möglich zurück
schlagen
wir müssen unseren verletzten
nationalstolz wiederherstellen wir
werden mit ihm krieg führen müssen auch
wenn wir es nicht wollen aber sein
vergossenes blut muss gerecht werden die
meisten von uns sind einfach nur fertig
in den ruf nach rache mischt sich bei
manchen auch wut über das leiden unter
den wirtschaftssanktionen diese
massendemonstration heute war höhepunkt
der dreitägigen staatstrauer
morgen wird sulimani in seiner
heimatstadt kehrmann beerdigt danach
beginnt das warten auf die reaktion der
iranischen militärs brase in teheran wie
sind diese massen einzuschätzen sind die
menschen freiwillig gekommen
also natürlich gab es gerüchte dass
vielen mitarbeitern in betrieben und
öffentlichen verwaltungen befohlen wurde
an der veranstaltung teilzunehmen
doch die meisten die wir heute gesehen
haben die waren wohl freiwillig da
schulen und universitäten waren
geschlossen und man hat ja im großen
stil kostenlose bus transporter aus den
umliegenden städten nach teheran
organisiert es ist sicherlich so dass
viele leute hier den general auch
tatsächlich geschätzt haben als eine art
beschützer der nation auch deshalb
dorthin gekommen sind und man darf das
glaube ich nicht unterschätzen das doch
es sich doch sehr sehr viele menschen
hier durch dessen ermordung gedemütigt
fühlen dass sie wütend sind und von der
regierung erwarten dass sie seinen tod
recht und insofern haben aber auch
einige uns gesagt dass sie eigentlich
keinen krieg wollen mit denen wir da
heute gesprochen haben sie wollen dass
die sanktionen aufgehoben werden und ich
glaube das ist genau das dilemma wie den
tod solle man solle man es ihnen ohne
die amerikaner dann doch zu einem
gegenschlag zu provozieren dankeschön
für diese einschätzung aus teheran afp
asel war dass der iranische general war
im irak von einer us drohne getötet
worden auch dort ist die empörung groß
das parlament forderte gestern den abzug
der gesamten us
geführten militärkoalition darauf hat
präsident jobs reagiert mit einer
deutlichen drohungen amerika werde gegen
den irak sanktionen verhängen wie sie
das land noch nicht gesehen habe so
trump wenn die regierung in bagdad us
truppen tatsächlich aus dem land werfen
sollte wie gefährlich die lage im nahen
osten eingeschätzt wird zeigt sich auch
an dem großen gesprächsbedarf in europa
am freitag gibt es ein sondertreffen der
eu außenminister in brüssel
am samstag wird die bundeskanzlerin
einen länger vereinbarten besuch in
moskau nutzen um mit präsident putin zu
sprechen über die reaktionen aus
deutschland und europa berichtet weniger
fragen von krieg und frieden drängen bis
in den kleinsten winkel auch hierher ins
bayerische seeon vor ursula von der
leyen zu gast ist
die eu kommissionspräsident in macht
klar dass sie den iran und seine
verbündeten für die schuldigen der krise
hält und von der leyen wirbt für
gespräche wir sehen ein aufschaukeln der
gewalt und deshalb ist es enorm wichtig
dass es gelingt diesen kreislauf der
gewalt der sich immer weiterentwickelt
zu durchbrechen und wieder einen raum
auch für die diplomatie zu schaffen
eine große sorge erklingt aus eu und
nato
dass der iran aus dem atom abkommen
aussteigt dass 2015 erst geschlossen
wurde
iran darf nie eine atomwaffe besitzen
wir teilen die sorge über iranische
raketentests und wir verurteilen
gemeinsam irans unterstützung für eine
vielzahl verschiedener terror
eine weitere sorge erwächst dem irak
dort hat das parlament zum abzug aller
ausländischen truppen aufgerufen
folgt die irakische regierung dem hätte
das auch konsequenzen für die bundeswehr
wir müssen und werden auch jede
entscheidung die die irakische regierung
mit blick auf die anwesenheit
ausländischer streitkräfte im eigenen
land trifft akzeptieren
ich möchte trotzdem auch in erinnerung
rufen dass es
auch gilt dass das erreichte nicht unter
dem eindruck der jüngsten ereignisse zu
rasch aufzugeben grüne und linke
allerdings sehen jetzt schon keine
grundlage mehr für die
ausbildungsmission der bundeswehr sollte
die irakische regierung diese resolution
umsetzen
dann mussten die bundeswehr hat müssen
alle anderen staaten ihre truppen
zurückziehen ansonsten wollen sie
automatisch zu einer besatzungsmacht
werden
berlin und europa im krisenmodus eine
woche der diplomatie beginnt zur csu wie
jedes jahr treffen sich die
bundestagsabgeordneten zur winterklausur
in oberbayern für einiges aufsehen
sorgte parteichef söder schon am
wochenende mit seiner forderung die
große koalition müsse sich verjüngen
außerdem will die csu änderungen bei der
landwirtschaft und der rente patricia
schäfer berichtet ungewohnte bilder von
der csu klausur in seeon 2000 landwirte
nutzten den tagungs auftakt heute für
ihren protest viele kleinbauern fürchten
um ihre existenz
sie fordern faire lebensmittelpreise und
weniger auflagen csu chef markus söder
stellte sich teilweise hinter ihre
forderungen zum beispiel bei der kritik
an der düngemittelverordnung und dem
wunsch nach mehr wertschätzung
die csu kämpft aber nicht nur um die
landwirte viele forderungen der
christsozialen im bundestag zielen
insgesamt auch die mitte der
gesellschaft entlasten familien
unterstützen und sparer schützen wir
haben deswegen auch einen neuen
vorschlag in die rentendebatte mit
eingebracht und zwar eine vierte säule
der rentenversicherung zu schaffen
in die der staat für jeden bürger
einbezahlt vom ersten lebensjahr an das
erste mal überhaupt macht ihr mal einen
vorschlag für die junge generation und
nicht nur für die jetzige aktuelle
situation
also wir werden gefordert sein
zukunftsanleihe machen wir wirklich
genügend für hightech für innovation und
digitalisiert csu chefs oder
positioniert sich als macher der auch an
die zeit nach der groko denkt und neuen
schub für die bundesregierung fordert
dem vorstoß zur kabinettsumbildung
übrigen hatte er nicht mit der cdu
abgesprochen namentlich der
parteivorsitzenden
wir waren da im gespräch aber nicht
vorher morgen wird es den direkten
austausch geben dann ist cdu-chefin
kramp karrenbauer gast bei der klausur
der schwesterpartei neues jahr neues
glück darauf setzt auch die fdp bei
ihrem traditionellen dreikönigstreffen
richtig rund lief es 2009 10 nicht die
partei ist zwar wieder im
europaparlament in sachsen und
brandenburg aber scheitert sie an der
fünf-prozent-hürde
bundesweit liegen die liberalen in
umfragen zwischen sechs und acht prozent
so wird parteichef lindner um
enttäuschte coco wähler aus stuttgart
eva schiller eine klare richtung
vorgeben dass es die herausforderung
beim dreikönigstreffen der fdp und
parteichef lindner hat ein problem
seine liberalen profitieren bislang kaum
von der wenig beliebten großen koalition
das soll sich ändern lindner zielt jetzt
auf neue wählergruppen auch auf arbeiter
und wir gehen vor die werkstore um mit
den menschen darüber zu sprechen was
ihnen wichtig ist und es ein irrtum zu
glauben dass alle facharbeiterinnen und
facharbeiter linke politik wollten und
alle landwirtinnen und landwirte rechte
politik wollen was die menschen in
unserem land suchen ist eine alternative
aus und für die politische mitte und das
sind die fragen demokraten beim
klimaschutz setzt die fdp auf innovation
statt auf regeln generalsekretären
teuteberg bemüht bei ihrer dreikönigs
premiere ein altgedientes fdp mantra
verbote sind einfach eine möglichkeit
staatlicher eingriffe aber in den
seltensten fällen die beste und klügste
insofern finde ich können wir in diese
debatten sehr gelassen gehen verbote
ohne schaum vor dem mund aber mit guten
argumenten abzulehnen liebe freunde
die one man show von christian lindner
wird von manchen in der partei
kritisiert als signal dürfen diesmal
auch andere auf die bühne
mitregieren möglichst zweistellig werden
dass es ihr ziel von den wählern gehört
werden die wohl größte herausforderung
nach dem tragischen unfall in südtirol
hat sich die zahl der toten auf sieben
erhöht eine junge frau erlag ihren
verletzungen
der verantwortliche autofahrer wurde
nach bozen ins gefängnis gebracht im
wintersportort luther war der 27 jährige
am sonntag in eine gruppe junge deutsche
ski-touristen gerast er hatte fast zwei
promille alkohol im blut
vor gut zwei jahren begann die miete
bewegungen nach den ersten
anschuldigungen gegen ex hollywood mogul
harvey weinstein
seit heute steht er vor gericht in new
york erschienen
der 67 jährige zum prozessauftakt mehr
als 80 frauen darunter superstars wie
angelina jolie oder salma hayek werfen
ihm sexuellen übergriffe vor in dem
verfahren geht es um die vorwürfe von
zwei frauen bei einer verurteilung droht
sonst ein lebenslange haft deutschland
wird seine klimaziele 2020 nicht
erreichen das hat die große koalition
links zu geben müssen jetzt zeigt sich
dass die bundesrepublik etwas besser
dasteht als erwartet nochmal zur
erinnerung deutschland wollte seine co2
emissionen bis zu diesem jahr eigentlich
um 40 prozent senken eben vergleich zu
jetzt liegen dem zdf zahlen vor die
zeigen im vergangenen jahr wurden
immerhin 35 prozent geschafft florian a
es sind daten die selbst die forscher
überraschen hier im thinktank agora
energiewende wo sie die deutsche
klimabilanz analysieren und für 2009/10
unerwartetes fest
die co2-emissionen sanken um mehr als 50
millionen tonnen auf ein rekordtief die
ursache eindeutig wir sehen dass 2019
die kohleverstromung in deutschland
deutlich zurückgegangen ist steinkohle
-30% braunkohle minus 20 prozent grund
für den rückgang der europäische co2
emissionshandel co2 zertifikate kosten
hier mittlerweile so viel dass
kohlestrom nicht immer rentabel ist und
kraftwerksbetreiber daher die produktion
drosseln aufgefangen wurde der rückgang
durch erneuerbare energien 2009 10 kam
erstmals mehr strom aus sonne und wind
als aus kohle und kernkraft zusammen
deutschland also wieder auf klima kurs
nein sagen die forscher
denn ausgerechnet der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien hakt was heute
sowohl der lobbyverband als auch das
umweltministerium beklagen
deswegen muss das ruder jetzt wieder
umgeschwenkt werden brauchen mehr
ambitionen und relevanten zubau der
erneuerbaren energien
es muss ein deutliches signal geben dass
dieser ausbau in diesem jahr eben auch
schon wieder eine dynamiker fährt die
unseren klimazielen gerecht wird
im verkehrssektor übrigens stiegen die
co2-emissionen den daten zufolge wieder
an
der grund immer mehr und immer größere
autos die deutsche klimabilanz 2019 also
nur auf den ersten blick positiv der
rückgang beim co2 ausstoß in deutschland
alle aktuellen infos dazu finden sie bei
uns auch online unter heute de und in
der zdf- heute- eindringliche appelle
für mehr klimaschutz gab es gestern
abend auch in hollywood bei der
verleihung der golden globes die
schauspielstars zeigten sich
klimabewusst so nahm zum beispiel
jennifer aniston den preis für ihren
kollegen russell crowe entgegen er war
wegen der verheerenden buschbrände in
seiner heimat australien geblieben
gegessen wurde übrigens vegan aus den
usa eines kampfes
schaulaufen zu den golden globes
schleifen und puffärmel dominieren
dieses jahr als wolle sich hollywood in
eine heile fantasie welt retten doch die
buschbrände in australien und der
klimawandel
sie bestimmen die politischen aussagen
ein grünes set filme ökologisch korrekt
zu drehen das ist für mich wichtig wir
müssen mehr tun es reicht noch lange
nicht auf fork in phoenix will mehr tun
er gewinnt den golden globe als bester
schauspieler in einem film drama und
nimmt seine kollegen in der branche in
die pflicht wir müssen nicht mit
privatjet von palm springs zu den globes
und zurück fliegen
phoenix erhält seinen preis für seine
rolle als superschurke in joker in der
königskategorie bestes filmdrama gewinnt
überraschend der kriegsfilm 1917 sie
marschieren eine volle dafür gibt es
auch den preis beste regie gewinner des
abends der film once upon a time in
hollywood er gewinnt als beste komödie
und für das beste drehbuch
als bester nebendarsteller siegt brad
pitt
hollywood versucht sich im kampf gegen
den klimawandel
allerdings wurde der blumenschmuck aus
ecuador eingeflogen und das
mineralwasser aus island ist noch luft
nach oben sehen wir studieren norbert
und ganz frisch zum abschluss der
vierschanzentournee in bischofshofen ja
gerade eben zu ende gegangen und leider
ohne das ganz große happy end für den
deutschen hoffnungsträger karl geiger
er wurde heute zweiter das reichte nicht
für den sieg in der gesamtwertung den
goldenen adler holte der pole dawid
kubacki nach dem ersten durchgang liegt
karl geiger auf platz zwei hinter david
kubacki aus polen der auch die
gesamtwertung anführt
dann fliegt geiger im achten und letzten
sprung der tournee auf 136 meter
das reicht zu tages platz zwei aber er
rutscht auf den dritten platz der
gesamtwertung hinter dem norweger marius
den weg zurück der weltmeister von 2009
10 auf der kleinen schanze kubatzki
behält die nerven 140 eineinhalb meter
der komfortable vorsprung reicht den
polen zu seinem ersten vier schanzen
tournee sieg nach garmisch und kamil
stoch der dritte pole der diesen erfolg
erregt und zum handball der hat das dhb
team drei tage vor dem em-auftakt auch
sein zweites testspiel gewonnen gegen
österreich die deutschen handballer
gewannen mit 32 zu 28 ein verdienter
sieg wenngleich die mannschaft in der
offensive schwächen zeigte generalprobe
mit schönheitsfehlern für das dhb team
zu viele vergebene chancen österreich
neben schweden und norwegen gastgeber
der em profitiert auch von
flüchtigkeitsfehlern hält lange mit 15
14 die führung zur halbzeit für
deutschland die mannschaft von
bundestrainer prokop nach der pause mit
mehr konzentration
em debütant patrick zieker bester werfer
mit sechs toren 32 28 der entstand bis
zum em-start muss prokop noch einen
spieler aus seinem 17 köpfigen kader
streichen
trauer um eine deutsche torwart legende
hans tilkowski ist im alter von 84
jahren gestorben
der einstige bvb-keeper und
nationaltorhüter wird immer mit dem
umstrittenen wembley-tor in verbindung
bleiben bei der deutschen wm
finalniederlage 1966 gegen england nach
seiner karriere als torhüter und trainer
engagierte er sich für kinder aus kriegs
und krisengebieten und bekam dafür das
bundesverdienstkreuz
die kosten als der erste torwart wir
jetzt so lange fußballer des jahres
wurde das ist ein dankeschön
beim wetter ist gefrierender regen ein
thema mehr dazu gleich von esther lee
das heute journal um viertel vor zehn
mit marietta slomka
wir danken für ihr interesse wünschen
ihnen einen schönen abend und morgen
wieder da bin ich auch wieder sehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter etwas regen und
schnee erreicht uns von westen her sehe
ich hier in blau eingezeichnet und das
wird dann bis zum nachmittag uns einmal
überqueren richtung südosten oder regen
kommt in der zweiten nachthälfte
unbekannt gefrierend sein und zwar hier
sehen sie es schon im westen
eingezeichnet der boden ist teilweise
gefroren und dementsprechend kann es zu
glatten straßen kommen ganz im osten ist
es trocken im südosten da bildet sich
nebel
und hier sehen sie die temperaturen sie
liegen etwa um die null grad marke also
durchaus große gefahr hier von glätte
aber nur vorübergehend eine zweite
nachthälfte bis etwa in den vormittag
hinein
eben genau zu berufsverkehr zahlt im
südosten ist es kälter bis -6 grad ganz
im osten minus zwei grad morgen im
tagesverlauf ziehen die wolken relativ
rasch in den südosten schneefallgrenze
bei 500 metern
viel wird es nicht sein im nordwesten da
zeigt sich sogar mal die sonne die
temperaturen erreichen zwei grad im
südosten und 10 grad ganz im westen
deutschlands die nächsten tage am
mittwoch wird es im norden regnen sonst
bleibt es trocken und relativ ruhig bei
zwei bis zwölf grad donnerstag ist es
dann gar nicht mehr ruhig da wird
stürmisch mit regen vor allem im norden
bei 6 bis 13 grad
ein schöner abend